hello everybody clearly it's laundry day
for me because I don't usually wear this
shirt
um but keeping the retro alive whatever
uh let's talk about keeping the retro
alive with one of our darkest hours in
looney-tune history um
did it get darker than that ah I mean
BAM action wasn't great but I think it
was a nice Jam yeah oh so okay so we're
gonna talk about this movie that a lot
of people still like but I think it's
one of those things for it's I think
it's kinda like the same way they like
Saved by the Bell is I guess yeah come
on lay off it but I hold a really high
respect for the Looney Tunes okay if
that's where you're coming from if it's
like Saved by the Bell then that's okay
I can see that but no fella more away by
the belly shit but no I can get on board
with that if that's where your cover if
you're trying to say it's legitimately
good I know by how people are confusing
like that feeling which I mean okay if
you really like it and it's like no come
on I really enjoyed this go ahead and
like it no problem but I mean just just
just try and keep in mind what your try
to keep in mind the two Giants you're
talking about here I mean really it's
like the Looney Tunes to which to me is
like you know my Michael Jordan I me
that's like a huge thing and then also
the Michael joined himself which really
I mean for a guy that is just like this
big icon this big hero to everybody he's
really not made that interesting and
people had said that those who have
actually talked to him in their views
and stuff that he is actually really
interesting but he's got to keep that
kind of quiet for the persona are you
saying they should have cast Shaq
instead maybe you know maybe he's an
interesting guy - who knows um but but I
kind of get it - it's like the icon the
all-american hero you gotta be as
non-threatening as possible uh but you
can at least be funny and the Looney
Tunes were just like the height of
comedy for me and I think one of the
reasons people deuced one of the reasons
people liked it then and some people
like it now is not that they liked the
movie they liked the idea of the movie
the idea is awesome Michael Jordan and
bug
bunny like battling aliens how can you
not be on board for that is your I'm
paper the idea of shack foo is aweso
Sissis man hey that's still classic my
friend but they're doing the reboot
oh they they did Kickstarter for there's
definitely a fan base rahat too but I
think again it's kind of the same thing
like we know this is kind of corny let's
just have fun with it um but they're
saying what I have fun with it's the
lane toons and I think for me I really
want to talk about this cuz there's some
sort of like I feel it was like 30th
anniversary of like either Michael
Jordan or like you know Michael Jordan's
shoes or something like that I don't
know it is some Air Jordans Air Jordans
Christ you grew up in Chicago between 88
92 I had a pair I have the pumps I'll
tell you they did shit they didn't do a
goddamn thing we pumped oh oh yeah go
jump higher and I was like they didn't
do a goddamn thing
fucking ripoff of all the cool here's
your also white so it's not like you
could trim too because I think you would
add much anyway um but but yeah so they
did this thing where it's like you know
now we're gonna talk to Bugs Bunny about
you know reuniting with Michael Jordan
and stuff it's just this little thing on
ESPN and it's like okay what the fuck am
I expecting but it's like I don't will
you put Bugs Bunny's name on something
I'm expecting fucking Bugs Bunny
why did you watch this because I sudden
something pulls out of my facebook so
I'm like okay well that's it cuz I like
Bugs Bunny and even some of the
commercials they did with Michael Jordan
and bugs playing like they weren't that
bad they're okay for a short little
15-second you know vignettes or whatever
but yeah and they you just see it it's
like clearly like the same people
they're just like what we saw Space Jam
we could write for Bugs Bunny cuz that
was Bugs Bunny it was just like the most
dead humorless thing you've ever seen
like the newscaster that or the
sportscaster they had on there was
funnier than Bugs Bunny and that should
not be the case uh and so I guess I just
really hold like this high esteem for
like the Looney Tunes and lunch money
and just what an icon they are and when
they come along with something that's
just clearly like oh we don't looney
tunes you know pie in the face what's up
doc and like they think that's kind of
it but it's like there was so much great
comedy to them and it really weren't
that many pies in the face uh
our catcher they're more with Daffy than
the weirwood they're a couple joy uh it
was more than just Pie face it was more
than that um there's a lot of
cross-dressing that is - that was the
secret my friend that's what you're
missing
bumps buddy shall warn address and phone
you got the way it's all it's just just
a big drag show that was the secret of
the Looney Tunes just drag um but no and
it's one of those things where it's like
this movie comes out with like this
really cookie cutter plot that you know
it's like you're not expecting to make
sense go insulting cookie cutters like
okay
it's like I'm not expecting to make
sense I'm really next not even one we're
not even paper-thin so thin it doesn't
exist but so I'm not expecting much I'm
just expecting something funny
it has fucking Bill Murray in it and
you're like dude let's seal is really
good but that was a little bit with the
salad he didn't want to be there yeah
but that was the shitty Bill Murray
years we forget by a larger than life we
forget that somewhere after Groundhog
Day and Ghostbusters to Bill Murray's
career just yeah
like people forget that now like after
Watson translation although it's like Oh
Bill Murray's back like but if you
didn't grow up during that time like you
Millennials were like born in 2000 and
no only this Bill Murray and whatever
classics you saw as a kid like
Ghostbusters there was a whole Lost
Decade
during during that Dark Age of film like
just an editorial on it was during that
time it was such a Dark Age it almost
killed Bill Murray although she was
amazing in wild things that is like the
he was a lesson in that
oh yes yes he was but uh yeah so you got
the he so obviously didn't care about
the movie he called what their new
Looney tune Lola which you could just go
on forever about what a terrible guy
that is what that's all I remember from
that character is that one line that's
her big you know Luna helmet nice blood
I otherwise I'm like I don't remember
her having a personality I don't
remember any lines
I don't worry anything about her oh and
I gave her tits yeah boobies yeah the
whole bunny movies thing so that's all I
remember is she had bunny tits but she
had bunny boobies and she said nice butt
get some great character yeah right
there uh and so didn't care that he just
called her girl bunny which I love he's
just like you know puncture gonna go
here deaf you're gonna do this girl
funny
you're gonna fall like he doesn't even
care enough to cuz she leaves such an
impact
yeah Healy you know she leads such an
impact that you know she just knows the
girl by which to be fair he called her
exactly what she was it was a girl
supposed to be a girl bugs and it's like
well we'll make your sexy cuz that's a
personality right sexy I think there's a
personality this goes back to the
Cinderella argument where we don't need
some great feminist icon but something
nothing just one random thing and then
all all these people they're coming out
like when I talked about the the new
Looney tune show which I get if people
don't like I love I thought it's so much
fucking closer to Louie tunes than
fucking Space Jam but you know because I
had the character the characters were
there and they're a different
environment uh but Lola they just
finally made funny they made her
enjoyable they got a great comedian to
do her voice and she just brought this
new energy and life to her and there was
like she's not the original I don't I
just the other one I thought was just so
good and so strong and oh yeah nobody
you save you regional now Space Jam Lola
bunny which is confessed I guess that's
the original by virtue of that's her
first appearance but that since there's
a saga bullshit you're like she's so
developed yet she was developed and
that's why I see you liked her uh but no
it's one of those things where it's like
it had huge tracts of left and I
definitely understand like you know like
we designed a mail no really I got a
there are people no get come out come
out you friggin weirdos come out and
defend your original Lola bunny show him
that you exactly yes they're they're
real they're all too real
oh she so has no personality that I even
forgot she existed till that new cartoon
came out yeah no it's and they they
tried to like shoe her in like you know
like a Great America you'll be here's
bugs who's happy here's Lola doesn't
even sound loony not even lulu-nee made
so obviously
product of the 90s name um and you know
here's the thing - again I know I'm not
supposed to relight come on just lean
tunes with Michael Jordan so what but
again Looney Tunes are a big fucking
deal to me and it's like here's a new
Looney tune uh female Looney tune you
know all we had was like granny
maybe Tweety for a while and finally
this new one comes in and it's just like
the oh we don't really know how to write
women yet or at least kid shows didn't
know how to write women yet so it's like
it's like we have maybe three or four
good female characters and they're all
from the Disney I wouldn't dude no I
take it back you Warner Bros the tiny
toons and maniacs they did them pretty
wait so really yeah okay no that's what
pisses me off even more that waterbars
was doing Looney Tunes cartoons they
just weren't coldly Tunes cartoons they
were called tiny toons of your call Anna
maniac Han and they were not wrap my
head around like they're still stuck on
that version of Allah was so worth
defending like no there's so many people
I knew whenever new ones do I mean the
new one the new one is just some valley
girl flake but no no she's psychotic -
that's what I'm but she's yeah she's
psychotic so it's not that different but
at least she was funny yeah it's a funny
new episode Zena that sure I remembered
much more than anything in space check
ya know there is a character that is
kind of my whole problem with Space Jam
though cuz you said we were gonna do
this today and I'm wracking my brain
because like on Assad's on Space Jam I
don't even really have any because the
movie left so little impact that I
haven't thought about it once once since
we reviewed it years at how many how old
is that review four years uh yeah maybe
my it was it was one of the really early
one that early 106 I presume I haven't
thought about it once not what that's
how little of an impact that film is
left on me like I don't even know what
to say except it just bored the crap out
of me and it's just Michael Jordan being
a corporate shill but and I mean that
giving credit he's really good at that
yeah I mean I mean he's made more money
at that the probably doing basketball
I'm sure and he's likable amid generic
sort of hey I'm not I my shoes yeah
I'm not offensive and I'm good at what I
do come on give me a free pass you know
what I do you can do so much more than I
can do is Michael fucking Jordan from
Chicago like how we're not gonna sit
here and rip um I had a bound to it
we're not gonna be able to get I mean we
could but we would have to like book the
first flight out of here am I going to
hiding no but they're really it's like I
I can't even I really can't I mean it is
Michael Jordan you can't really
bad-mouthed
Michael Jordan uh so it's one of those
things where it's like I get it and I
get the idea for it but just oh yeah we
Knights in this movie I just remembered
yeah a few other players I think as well
are in it um they get hit by a um you
know ceiling that's about it that all
they do um I just remember at the time
the only story I have attached this
movie is at the time when it came out my
cousin saw it and my cousin was the
biggest basketball fan
Bulls fan lived in Chicago the whole
time during their run in the 90s and I
was like hey so how was it he's like
yeah it's it's uh yeah it was uh it's
yeah this way it's it's okay
yeah begin like nothing positive to
really say about it but he didn't want
to say he hated it either cuz Michael
Jordan's name was on it I because I'm
paper it's just like you look at it on
paper Michael Jordan plus the Looney
Tunes
Plus Bill Murray and way night who was
funny at the time he was on sign he's
still probably funny he's just not
around I show up Jurassic Park and I'm
just like you look at the sheet of paper
that says is there like why can't see
anything bad about it cuz how could that
I must be wrong I must be wrong it's a
favorite night of women no no this can't
be bad there that is can't be bad and
wrong with me George Lucas and Liam
Neeson and like in Yoda's baguette it is
a job I must be wrong and then that's
the devil with a double lightsaber I'm
wrong something I did something wrong
like that's all like that like the ended
seriously that was like the reaction at
the time everybody like I mean the
critics hated it obviously but everybody
else is like well it's it's
Anna I can't like it's I it's harmless
yeah this armless guys I know what is
for kids it's for kids either it's there
it's there i knowledge i saw it and
that's pretty much my thought I
acknowledge I've seen this oh I have no
thoughts about this movie of none
there's just nothing to talk about
I I mean for me it's something where
it's like this could have been like if
this came out now if they tried this now
with all sort of this brilliant
combination of corporate selling out but
also ingenious storytelling the first
thing pots of Mines lego movie that's a
total the lego movie how can you get
more of a corporate cell just in a title
but it's a brilliant movie and I think
it could've been somehow like a movie if
you this was done no I bet you would
have been good I bet you they will put
something so you don't say no we need
the Nike movie away we had that it was
called Space Jam yeah uh it wasn't very
good
um I yeah you know I acknowledge to that
if Bugs Bunny is kind of like Mickey
Mouse or Superman that they are a nod to
even Michael Jordan they are such big
icons that their rival Jordan is no
longer human he is just a cartoon
sucessor but there's such big icons they
are really difficult to write for
because they represent so much that we
respect and we look up to but people can
forget like with Bugs Bunny and the link
toons especially they were doing stuff
that like not a lot of people were doing
at the time and that was kind of the
charm of it um so and sadly it looks
like we're almost running out of a dis
space here I apologize if I wiped this
oh so matter I have nothing else yeah so
we're Kagan I don't know anyway but I
understand that it's hard to write for
them but it to me it's not the zany
nough stuffiness it's the fact that they
know how to still be new fresh and funny
and that's part of what I liked about
the newer show though I can understand
people not Gambhir with that but they
were still characters and they were
relatable and they were weird and funny
and you wanted to get behind them
because they were so strange because
they were the oddballs they were the
outsiders
you know Mickey Mouse is a winner and a
nice guy you know Goofy's kind of goofy
whatever the donald duck was the only
outsider and that's why you know those
cartoons are always the photos it's a
two-hour commercial and that's not right
Michael Jordan and the loiters together
shouldn't just be a two-hour commercial
it should definitely be a part of it
there's no way you can't do that by
should be Manos gonna save it's not
somehow two-hour commercial
I think somebody in advertising failed
but if you die but that's why I guess
it's why I can't tell you it's like how
do you talk about a commercial I mean I
know we did the commercial specials but
it was so sorry a those are hilariously
awful like this isn't even that it's
just it's like watching a Nike
commercial being like there's a Nike
commercial like I just don't know what
to say so I think I got most of what I
had to say if you like it fine cuz you
got a lot of harsh feelings about Space
Jam uh you know I do I've a lot hard
feelings I have in my hands feelings
about that money too I can't complain I
I have harsh harsh things to say about
Mamma Mia no I I have I have a real love
for the Lloyd toons I think that they
deserve better than how they were
treated here they're animated well I'll
give him that
but I guess I haven't met enough people
in my life who defend the hell out of
that movie so I don't care it's just
like oh this is where those corporate
shill things and that there's a lot
online I can definitely say that Wow
yeah it is surprising I'm not gonna lie
how many of those people just saw when
they were 5 years old
I'm sure all of them fighting any grown
adult anybody over the age of 17 who saw
them and wants to defend the film good
luck yeah I don't know what to it's like
give a sh looks bad even know what to
tell you that is like the ultimate
defense of movies can add I get if you
were 5 is it yes oh it is you like it
and fight enough but uh yeah I'm still
gonna hate a man so uh that's about it
we have like a minute left to film I'm
still not gonna care cuz there's nothing
to talk about
we got a lot to film here so I'll just
say goodbye and take care of see the
next one
hopefully I'll remember the movie